Hello everybody my name is Markiplier, and welcome back to Tattletail
Now, I was a little bit dumb in the last  episode because I was rushing very much so
And uh, when I'm rushing it usually means that I'm about to die
because I'm making a lot of noise.
And
I kind of... made a mistake here because
I don't necessarily have everything that I need to be able to do this
but unfortunately...
Oh!
No, fortunately I don't have any needs to take care of.
So, I just need to be a bit more patient about it. And when...
When- when Mama comes...
When Mama comes...
I just gotta be careful, because
I don't naturally make any noise when I'm just by myself.
So if I'm by myself,
I don't necessarily need to do anything
to make sure that I get away from Mama.
So I just gotta be quiet.
See even in the darkness......
I don't even need to worry about anything else
making complaints about the fact that it's dark.
I just need to be my own person.
I don't even have to frickin' move!
I just have to be very, VERY...
very AGGRESSIVELY understanding about what I'm doin'.
Oh that sounds bad!
*Grinding Sound*
But everything SHOULD be okay
if I'm just very quiet!
Isn't that right...
Mama.
If that is your real name?
I think?
Yeah!
That's it, because Mama does eventually go away,
which means that I...
...Can then run in here,
grab what I need,
The little mouthy pieces of shi-
ME LOVE PLAY TIME WITH Y Ouuu...
Tattletail: [wE lOVe Play tIMe with YOuuu...]
Mark: uuugh fuck, God damn it!
Oh no, oh no...
Tattletail: [MaMa HATES youuuu~!
SHUTUP ABOUT MAMA!
I know MaMa hates me!
Tattletail [hEheeheEE~]
Tattletail: [MaMa's wATchiiing~]
Aw FUCK I forgot-
I forgot you needed to be GROOMED!
Tattletail: [brrrUSH mEEeee...]
I FORGOT YOU NEEDED TO BE GROOMED!
Tattletail: [brrrUSH mEEeee...}
...Aw fuck...
Tattletail: [brrrUSH mEEeee...]
I think she was upstairs and not down here
..AH!
FUCK!!! [The moment when mark knew he fucked up.]
Goddamn it goddamn it.
Tattletail: [brrrUSH mEEeee...]
I know you needed to be brushed but SHUT THE FUCK UP right about now...
TT: [brrrUSH mEEeee...]
Mark: Right about now, funk soul brother!
Woah...
That's a bit closer than I'd like
TT: [brrrUSH mEEeee...]
I GET IT SHUT UUUUP!
Goddamn it!
TT: [brrrUSH mEEeee...]
I FORGOT!
Tattletail: [brrrUSH mEEeee...]
Goddamn it GODDAMN IT GODDAMN IT
AW FUCK
Tattletail: [brrrUSH mEEeee...]
Well this ain't good!
But I don't-
YEAH! See!?
TT: [HEe hee hee hee hEE!]
MaMa's done!
Tattletail: [Give me a trEAT!]
HA! Shut the FUCK UP!
You're gonna starve and be dirty until the end of your days!
You little SHIT
Tattletail: [Give me a trEAT!]
Noooo!
Tattletail: [More!! MORE!!!]
More MORE more more...
Find a friend in the garrrrooge
In the gaRAAGE
So then, since everything is hunky dory
I just got to do that and make sure this one gets fed...
And then everything should be fine
Which means that I gotta grab 'em,
and then sprint in, get him fed, and then hide from MaMa.
...And then it's as simple as that and then I'm good to go, right?
...Probably...
Here we goooo... ruUNNNNN
Tattletail: [Me TATTletaaail, mE lOVe yoOUU!]
Okay, where is she?
Tattletail: [MaMa's COMIIIiiiing~!]
Mark: I know MaMa's coming!
Tattletail: [Give me a trEAT!]
Where is she?
I think she's in there...
Tattletail: [Give me a trEAT!]
SHADDUP
She's over there.
Tattletail: [Give me a trEAT!]
Come on come on come on come on....EAT! EAT! EAT! EAT! EAT!
Now shut the fuck up.
Just let me do my goddamn job.
Oh shit...
Oh shit that's fine
Tattletail: [Hee hee hee!]
YYYYEEEEAAAHHHH!
YEAH!!
THAT'S HOW YOU DO IT, BABY!!!
THAT'S HOW YOU DO IT!!
heeEEH I don't sound very confident about what I'm doing,
but I-...
dat's how you do it.
So, then you gotta do that
Tattletail: [MORE MORE]
OKAY easy!
*reading* Party supplies, pick up Tattletail.
I don't wanna do that. I don't wanna do that.
Tattletail: [DecoRAtions!]
I don't wanna do that.
*reading* Supply run: find the cupcakes upstairs.
I know where they are!
They're right upstairs on the-
They're right upstairs on the counter!
I know that for a fact!
I've seen them before, not the counter the uh-
they're on the- the table
Tattletail: [Playtime for mEE! BiiIIG FUUuun.]]
BIG BONS
I know.
So I just gotta gun this
And then that's good.
I DON'T KNOW WHY I GOTTA BRING TATTLETAIL ALONG WITH ME
JUST TO MAKE MY LIFE HARDER!
I know that for a faaaccttt.
Tattletail: [more more]
*reading* Supply run: find some festive lights
...you mean like on the Christmas tree?
Ugh I don't like the uh fuck
Tattletail:[MaMa saw yoUUU]
No she didn't!
She didn't see anything!
Okay, so I know for a fact I can wait out MaMa right here
And I'm a patient maaan!
I'M A PATIENT BIG BOY!
So I know...
I KNOW
I know that she's a
calm woman...
Oh hi! Hi MaMa!
I see you in the window there
I see you spying on me!
Tattletail: [Give me a trEAT!]
Oh shut up.
Don't do anything to ruin my life.
Tattletail: [Give me a trEAT!]
Don't do anything to ruin my life
It's gonna be fine
Okay, and there ya have it!
Tattletail: [Give me a trEAT! Hee hee hee]
Back up, back up and back- ready to gooo!
Tattletail: [Give me a trEAT!]
Okay, and it's-it's-it's literally as simple as that, right?
Um yeah, I'm pretty sure...
Tattletail: [Give me a trEAT!]
YYUUUUUPPP!
Kay, run, run, run.
Gotta groom
SHUT UP
Tattletail: [Give me a trEAT!]
Go ,go, go, go, gooooo!
Tattletail: [Hee hee hee hee]
Tattletail: [Me Tattletail. Me loOOVE you!]
Go go, go, goooOOooo.
Okay, gonna charge ya real quick.
Oh God, this takes forever!
Uhhhhhhh booski!
Okay and boop! Got it.
Okay.
Tattletail: [More more!]
I'm just going back to my safe spot.
*reading* Supply run: candles from the kitchen counter!? I was RIGHT THERE. GODDAMN IT.
Fuck.
Tattletail: [You're in big TROuble...]
No I'm not. You don't know that yet.
I know this is my safe spot!
I don't care if it seems cheap to you--ooh hey MaMa.
I don't care if it seems cheap to you, I KNOW WHAT I'M DOING!
Even though I do have all my needs met, I could make my way in there.
But I don't know if the checkpoint system is still as borked as it was before, so...
I ain't gonna risk shit on this one.
Oh boy.
Why couldn't my Mama wake up and help me?
My Mama just needs to grapple this thing; use her bear mom strength,
and just fuck this thing up!
Rip its head off!
Nonononono
That's as close as you can get!
That's as close as you can fucking get.
Tattletail: [Hee hee hee!]
Okay, there we go. Done and done and done and done.
Tattletail:[Me loOOVE playtime with yoUUU]
It's like an even amount of time when you're waiting for her
and an even amount of time when you're safe from her.
Tattletail: [Give me a trEAT!]
Candles on the kitchen counter...These ones?!
Yep! Okay. Got it.
Tattletail: [Give me a trEAT!]
Yee! Shut up! Just eat! EAT! EAT! EAT!
Oh Goddamn it. I need to brush him--nah fuck it!
TT: [Hee hee hee hee hee!]
Eh. I could do it with him making noise, it's just annoying to me.
Whoa.
Tattletail: [Me Tattletail. Me loOOVE you!]
WHAT THE FUCK IS HAPPENING?!
[Tattletails all chanting] [No more MaMa!]
WHAT THE FUCK?!
Let Tattletail join the seance?!
All Tattletails:[Brush me!]
What the fuck?! Light the candles?!
Tattletail: [Light the cANdles!]
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
What the fuck are you talking about?!
Oh my god their heads are rolling up into the back their eyes! (sic)
Oh my god!
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
That's fucking terrifying!
Tattletail:[ReWInd the tape]
How?! Be kind, rewind?! I don't have a VHS!
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
Oh god.
MaMa don't attack me!
Uuurrgggh
Ohhhhhh
Oh fuck! I wasn't looking for eggs!
I wasn't looking for eggs! I was dying!
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
*garbled music*
Goddamn it!
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
*garbled music*
I grabbed some eggs the last time I was playing this, I know that.
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
Uhhh fuck.
MaMa stole the candles...? [INDEED]
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
Can you guys shut up?! How is this happening?
Ohhh nooo
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
Why is-- Where? Where? Where? WHERE?
I'm not making any noise!
I'm not--whoa.
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
Nonononononono.
Nonononono.
I'm not making any noise, lady!
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
I'm not-- THEY'RE making the noise!
Not me!
Not me, baby!
Not me! You just go the fuck away!
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
I know we're doing some sort of demonic purge outta your programming here,
but you just let it happen
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
Just lay back, relax,
and, you know, go to hell!
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
Okay, I don't think she's going to go away.
Ooh, whoa.
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
Ohh okay. I think I know what I'm supposed to dooo.
Oh fuck.
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
Oh fuck. Ahh fucking GODDAMN it.
MaMa: [MaMa's coming...]
MaMa better not be! I don't want any of that!
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
Don't want any of that on my conscience--ah fucking goddamn it!
Why are you in there?
How does that make goddamn sense?!
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
Okay.
I know what I need to do. I need to break the vaaah-ses
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
And then--ah fuck they don't all... Eeee..
Eeee... Don't know how you got over there--ohhh fuck, you're gone again.
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
Okay. I know what I need to do, I just don't know where the eggs are!
She right outside the door?
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
YeeEEE!
Okay, just gotta be methodical about it.
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
Just gotta be nice and methodical.
Get through every room...
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
Oh fuck there she is. Okay. That's FINE.
She can be over there.
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
She can be over there. She can be over there.
She can be over there. That's totally fine.
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
Just gotta do this when she's not around.
There we go. Got another one!
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
Winner, winner, baby!
Winner, winner, baby.
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
Oh fuck. You're over there, which is fine
Cuz, that's out of range of this.
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
Shit.
Ohh she's gone again.
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
Okay--eehyayyayy
Okay. It's fine. Oooh.
Alright, um. PROBABLY shouldn't be staring at ya.
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
I don't know.
Fuck. Oh Goddamn it. Alright at least you moved.
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
YEE! Fuck. Okay, goodBYYYEEE
MaMa: [MaMa will look out for you...]
No MaMa will nooooot!
Ooh fuck hi. Okay. You know what?
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
I'm very quiet. I'm very quiet. I'm very quiet. I'm very quiet. I'm very quiet.
I'm very quiet. I'm very quiet I'm VERY quiet. I'm very quiet.
I am so quiet.
AHH! FUCKING NOOO!
NOOOO! She moved right as I shook it maybe...I don't know.
Maybe I should've got --oh fucking Goddamn it!
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
I was close! Whoa.
Where'd she go?
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
Fuck. Okay, she's right there
MaMa: [MaMa will look out for you...]
Nonononono
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
Don't do that , MaMa.
Just gotta get around this corner...
Oh fuck. She's gone Oooh fuck. Okay.
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
There. That's where you went before!
Oh god.
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
Eeee...
Okay, lemme just crack open this one
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
Ehhh!
Is that the last one? Place candles?
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
Re-light?
You stay there MaMa!
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
Stay there MaMa! No, don't move MaMa!
Don't move. I know this isn't making noise so you don't make a goddamn thing.
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
Yeah! Get fucked! I'm observing!
MaMa:[Come to MaMa...]
Nooooo
No mo' MaMa
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
*garbled music playing in reverse*
*TattleTail voices speaking in reverse*
*MaMa's voice speaking in reverse*
*garbled music playing in reverse*
All Tattletails: [No more MaMa!]
*MaMa's voice speaking in reverse*
*TattleTail voices speaking in reverse*
*noise like a skipping record*
...Okay...
Yaaay...?
Oooooookaaaayyyyyy...
Go to bed!
OHHH.
Oh just that simple, huh?
Ohh, am I free to go?
Well maybe, just maybe,
JUST MAYBE there'll be some egg around here... I don't know...
I don't know~
Unless they were just really well hidden in the last round but, maybe it's like:
Hey, it would be a little unfair to be hunting for those things
when everything is being DEATH.
I'll knock on my mom's door!
Ooh! Egg! Eggy!
Okay!
That's... How many do I have left?
Found egg 21 count--- 21 of 22! I'm good!
Okay, I just need to find one more!
I just need to find one more then I'm good, right?
It's gotta be one around here. That was 21 of 22. That means...
That means 22...
...has gotta be around here somewhere.
If I just look very hard before I go to bed...
I just wanna make sure that I cover all my bases before I even TOUCH that bed.
That I cover EVERY LAST square inch of this place before I even go to bed.
Alright. I'm not seeing it anywhere.
Which means that it must be--if 21 was over there, then 22 must be...
...after I... *sigh* go to bed. Ehh.
This is a risk, but I've looked absolutely everywhere.
Like, 100%. I have looked everywhere.
So...
I'm assuming...!
I don't know!
Is that gonna be the end of the game?!
*coughs*
I don't know.
Fuck...
Ahh. Oh I forgot! There's gotta be a Christmas day!
That's gotta be a thing that happens. I-I think. Yes?
Maybe?
Oooooh.
Okay, I don't have a flashlight anymore, but it's actually day!
Well that's lovely!
MOOOM! DAAAD! I had the wildest few days...
Oh god, it's so beautiful out!
Kay, so I gotta open my present, but it's 100% GORGEOUS out.
Look at all this!
LOOK at all this!
Oh boy, bet I--ah fuck. I thought I could open that.
But I got a lot of base to cover which means that I gotta be on the lookout.
For my pre-SANT.
Kay so my present is---ohh.
Hello?!
HEEEY!
Cupcake Wrapper!
Found egg #22. Collected 22 of 22!
I did it!
I think!
What does that mean?!
Did that do anything for me?
I don't know. Things look so weird in the daytime.
Oooookay...?
MAMA! MOOOM! DAAAD! MOOOM!
MOOOM!
Okay?
Well, I got all the eggs. Does that mean that I just do this? Is it gonna be Tattletail?
Do I WANT it to be Tattletail?
Ahhh...
I don't like that!
*ominous music begins to play*
I DON'T LIKE THAT!
WHY IS IT DOING THAT?
Why is it doing that? That doesn't need to happen!
It could be NOT that!
It could be anything BUT that!
Alright. You know what? I'm a big, brave boy!
With big, blue pants! I'm a big, brave boy!
I could do this! I'm a BRAVE boy!
...Or girl. I'm not sure...
Here we gooo!
I guess!
*ominous music gets louder*
Now open up the box?!
That doesn--
What's it gonna---What's it gonna do to-- oh-ho-kay.
That's--That's quick.
That's quick. That's much faster.
Tattletail: [PREsent for yoUUU]
Accept TattleTail's gift. I don't know if I want to!
Tattletail's Tag! *reading* This is Tattletail's special tag given at birth. He must REALLY like you!
*reading* Tattletail was born in delighful Decent, Illinois on 02/25/98.
*reading* Each Tattletail is handmade with love in our facility? Ooookay...
Baby-talkin' Tattletail!
Oh!
Waygetter Gold!
Golden flashlight!
*reading* New from Waygetter Electronics: The long-lasting golden flashlight!
You love it!
D-Do I love it? Wake up your MOM.
Whoa.
Whoa. This is some Waygetter flashlight!
MOOOM!
MMMOOOOOOM?!
O-Okay, why do I need to do that?
Why is that a thing that needs to be DOOONE?
I don't think this is appropriate for us
Okay...
Here we go...
*ominous music begins and quickly rises*
*ominous music stops suddenly*
Tattletail: [Thank you.]
OH!
Well what the fuck?!
WH-WHAT THE HELL HAPPENED?!!!!!
Was that the--wait was there any secret ending?!
What the fack was that?!
OH COME ON!
WHAT?!
Aw man, that would have made my life a lot easier if I had a fucking level select.
Oh gawd.
Okay. So I'm gonna look up about the secret ending because I have all of the eggs.
I just don't know what else to do.
Ohh okay.
So, uh, I get it now.
The good ending was what we got.
We didn't die on Christmas day.
That was the good ending!
I just didn't even know it because I hadn't even seen the bad ending!
So
When we opened that box, if you get all the eggs,
or if you don't get all the eggs, and you open that box, the box is empty.
There is no Tattletail in there.
There's only MaMa.
And MaMa kills you dead.
But,
anyway, that is Tattletail, and that is...
...fucking horrifying.
Really well done! I gotta say, really well done with what they did.
It became a little easy to game the mechanics after a while, but even so.
The-The arc that they crafted, and the buildup they had for the scares...
...was incredible. I loved it a lot. It really built up a lot.
Because it told you, it dropped you hints and red herrings from the get-go,
before the actual danger was there.
All while training you in what you were supposed to do.
It's a really well done--like from a game design standpoint, that's really well done.
And from a horror standpoint, I was really scared.
So,
Either way, thank you everybody so much for watching!
I hope you enjoyed this very much.
Let me know down in the comments below what you think and if there are any other secrets that I have missed,
so that you can help your fellow gamer out.
Thanks again!
And as always, I will see YOU in the next video!
BUH-BYE!